[Musique]
ce gouvernement n'a pas de stratégie et
ils imposent aux français chaque jour
l'humiliation l'humiliation des
attestations ubuesque l'humiliation de
la fermeture d'un certain nombre de
commerces de proximité qui n'ont
strictement rien demandé on a repoussé
18 à 19 heures ce qui est plutôt une
bonne chose probablement il aurait fallu
passer à 20 heures parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y avait une tout le monde se
bouscule à 18 heures c'est absurde
et puis un deuxième chose c'est certains
magasins qui sont fermées des petits
magasins mois dans la commune dont je
suis maire avoue qu'ils comprennent pas
moi même je ne comprends pas le
gouvernement n'a pas réussi à dépasser
le caractère arbitraire des décisions
qu'il prend dont on ne comprend pas
encore une fois ni le sens ni l'intérêt
et qui s'apparente plus à une punition
nous avons fait des exceptions pourquoi
mais tout simplement pour le moral des
français
c'est le cas pour les coiffeurs nous
l'avons fait parce qu'il ya des
professions prenez les fleuristes ils
font la moitié de leur chiffre
d'affaires pendant cette période de
printemps et derrière il ya tout
l'horticulture
nous l'avons fait pour les chocolatiers
parce que c'est pâques je ne dis pas que
c'est parfait c'est un message optimiste
qui a délivré hier soir le commissaire
européen chargé des vacances avec une
ambition affichée est bien le 14 juillet
nous avons la possibilité d'atteindre
l'immunité au niveau du continent sont
les personnes fragiles d'ici fin mai on
devrait pas être loin du but pour faire
diminuer la circulation du virus il faut
aussi que les plus jeunes moins fragile
mais qui si dissémine le virus forcément
leur fasse cet été si je voulais bien
mais nous n'allons nous on arrive à
l'été et l'automne
jamais au grand jamais nous n'arriverons
à obtenir une immunité collective n'a ni
au printemps ni à l'été ni même
probablement à l'automne puisque en
trois mois et demi nous avons réussi je
crois à vacciner
concernant les deux doses quoi 3 3 3% et
demi de français
nous restons sur les chiffres que nous
avons donné c'est à dire 10
millions de primo vacciner à la mi avril
et puis ensuite ça va augmenter parce
que les apports de vaccins vont
augmenter le maire socialiste de
marseille n'a pas de mots assez durs
pour décrire le carnaval qui s'est tenue
dans le centre-ville hier après midi
l'événement non déclarés a rassemblé
plus de 6500 personnes sans masque ni
respect des gestes barrières au delà de
l'aspect sanitaire
il y a eu en marge de la manifestation
comme souvent malheureusement et ça
c'est d'autant plus inacceptable des
personnes qui sont venues mal
intentionnés et qui ont participé
activement en fin de journée à de la
dégradation ce carnaval qui a été
visiblement organisée au son de tout le
monde déteste la police par l'extrême
gauche marseillaise est totalement
irresponsable
il faut évidemment prendre des sanctions
pour 2 contre des gens qui agissent
ainsi
et demain d'ailleurs des comparutions
immédiates et j'ai demandé à madame la
préfète de police des bouches du rhône
de prendre toutes les dispositions pour
identifier les organisateurs est de
permettre à l'autorité judiciaire de les
poursuivre je suis vraiment peiné parce
que c'est une attitude est irresponsable
qui va complètement contre les efforts
très importants des profils de santé en
tout premier lieu la prochaine crise qui
nous menaçait et qui nous menace aller
là c'est la crise de l'acceptabilité des
mesures les mesures ne sont plus
acceptables pourquoi parce qu'elles ne
sont pas comprises parce qu'elles sont
improvisés fait elle dit leur ras-le-bol
de la population très clairement et l'
envie de légèreté l' envie de se refaire
la fête mais malheureusement j'ai peur
que marseille le paye le paye cash
on peut pas maintenir comme ça sous
cloche un pays l'empêché de vivre en
paix chez la jeunesse de vivre empêcher
les gens de vivre et de faire croire les
culpabiliser systématiquement en faisant
croire des choses fausses et
scientifiquement c'est faux cette
histoire qu'il ya des clusters à
l'extérieur y en a pas eu un seul dans
le monde
le seuil d'acceptabilité
ou plutôt d'inacceptable it et des
mesures est dépassé c'est ça le problème
aujourd'hui auxquels nous sommes
confrontés selon le site coville tracker
au rythme actuel il faudrait attendre le
14 juin 2022 pour vacciner l'ensemble
des français